justement on continue avec l'euro 2016
les phases de poule viennent de se
terminer en huitième de finale la france
qui a terminé première du groupe à
affronter l'irlande 3e du groupe e dans
un derby yvelinoise sulfureux 40 minutes
séparent seulement les deux camps de
base de versailles où séjournent les
boys in green de clairefontaine le match
se disputera ce dimanche 26 juin à 15
heures à lyon on écoutait l'adjoint
délégué aux sports de la ville de
versailles
mécontent on poursuit les aventures avec
le plus formidable de jouer contre la
france
on est bien sûr convaincu qu'on en
entendra beaucoup parler de ce match
bon c'est ton jeu là pour nous et puis
le fait que ben on va dire souci une
petite revanche en 2010 le foncièrement
tort ce soir après sa passe est un très
beau match qui à mon sens veut très
ouvert